[Music]
let's go to daryl
in johnson city tennessee daryl what's
going on brother
i'm doing good how are you doctor john
i'm doing all right my man
you sound down this morning how are
things
oh it's good i work third shift so you
know i'm a little tired
[Laughter]
always glad to talk to you well always
glad to talk to you even though it's our
first time so what's up man
uh yeah my question is um me and my
ex-wife are recently going through
divorce
and i just want to know how it could
still be there for her
and my children man so give me the
details brother
oh well let's see we uh were together
for about
you know eight years we have two
beautiful kids
and uh then you know
we of course had issues like every
marriage
and we decided to separate
and then we decided did something happen
okay
it's more of me being dumb and
in the marriage and what does that mean
problems and
i do i decided to ask
another female about uh my marriage
problems
and you know that uh caused a lot of
issues
and did you cheat on your wife
no but i mean in the way me talking to
another woman is
infidelity but we didn't i didn't cheat
but you know
in a way that is cheating okay and so
ultimately
but that that happens
in fact i don't know many marriages
where that doesn't happen in some shape
form or fashion so
that in and of itself wouldn't lead to
divorce what was the
decision you guys came to that said hey
where i'm out
uh it was more of we were always better
friends than we were married
and uh we decided that
we would rather be separated and be a
united front for our children
than be married in final time
why didn't y'all decide just to not
fight all the time
i don't know you know we could we could
be in a room and you know within
10 minutes we'll get on each other's
nerves and just start fighting
you made the decision to dissolve your
family unit
and that's
hard and painful and incredibly
expensive
and a beating and grief
filled and all those things would
wouldn't it have been easier just to
like
decide to not fight it
it would have or just be like not about
that hey why don't i just respect
you and be kind and sure we can watch
that movie or
sure i'll quit eating that or whatever
the thing is i won't fart in the living
room i don't know what your things were
but
man yeah so is this thing is this a done
deal
it's over yeah it's it's definitely done
deal
you know where uh we go to court soon
afford it
to uh get it finalized um
and there's no going back i mean you
haven't you haven't given me
any you're calling to ask how you can
love your wife your
soon to be ex-wife well and you're
calling me to
ask how you can honor and love your kids
during the separation and while they
move into a different home or whatever
the custody arrangement will be
and you haven't given me any reason at
all
as to why y'all just kind of cashed it
out
other than you quit putting gas in the
car and then it slowly just sputtered
and stopped
and instead of filling it with gas y'all
just said ah let's just leave it on the
side of the road
you go that way i'll go this way you
haven't given me anything
you know what i mean yeah it's
like it sounds like you really still
like this lady
oh i mean yes i do still love her you
know
she's moved on um you know i've
i guess i haven't moved on but you know
i'm in a process of
you know trying to move past it and you
know
try to be there for my kids you know
so one of two things brother and then
i'll then i'll answer your question
either there's something big going on
here that you're not telling me which is
fine you don't have to
or there is a major major conversation
that's
been left unsaid there is a hard
conversation
that one of you said hey why don't we
just do this and then someone said yeah
we were better off this way anyway and
what about that and it's for the kids
and partridge and a pear tree
and suddenly both of you guys are
walking like the like those movies where
the person keeps looking back
right when the other person turns their
head and the other person looks back
right the other person turns their head
and then y'all just kept on walking
and so here's what i'll tell you we've
all heard stories about
folks meeting at the courthouse to go
finalize divorce and they just go to
breakfast and
make sure everybody's on the same page
and suddenly they say what are we doing
and if it's not too late i'll tell you
right now i don't care if she's quote
unquote moved on or you quote unquote
moved on y'all been together a decade
man
she's a part of you and if there's a
shred of you that says hey man is this
the only last nuclear option do we have
to hit this button
call her up and say hey do we have to
hit this button because man it is way
way easier to decide to quit fighting
that's an easy easy it's a simple easy
thing to do
it's hard but it's simple right
and you can re-change you can i mean
re-program yourself on how you talk to
one another and how you love each other
and how you show up for each other
and you're getting a bird's-eye view of
what the other side of this thing looks
like and it sucks
right yeah yeah because i always told
myself you know
when i got married i was gonna get
divorced because you know my parents
when i was you know younger they
divorced as well but that didn't go
uh good at all no never does man
it never does yeah yeah and i was like
you know
i'm gonna try my best and you know it
you know went sideways and
now we're divorcing but you know i told
them you know i'm gonna at least
you know get along with her you know
co-parents
and make sure that you know my kids know
they are loved and
we are both there for them
that cut i get that and it's it's
honorable that that's your approach
i get that but part of me sounds like
you
are
about to push a button to launch a
missile
and you're letting folks know hey i'm
gonna sweep up
all the damage i'm gonna clean it up
really nice
i promise i'm gonna sweep up all the
glass and the metal and
all the bodies i'm gonna sweep all that
up i will be a good cleaner
and i feel like just saying like
do you have to hit the button that's all
i'm asking so
man i'll tell you right now i've heard
it more than once
there's a shred of you that says hey can
we still make a go at this thing call
your wife
before she becomes your ex-wife and take
her out somewhere and have that hard
conversation
if it is what it is and that thing's a
foregone conclusion
here's how you um be there for your ex
and for your kids
you be there for your ex and for your
kids
see the challenge is you're gonna get
divorced and you're gonna have to end up
doing the things and working on the
things that would have kept you married
in the first place
you're gonna have to choose to not be
frustrated when she does the things that
make you annoyed and she's gonna have to
choose the same thing also
you're gonna have to choose to never try
to quote unquote win an engagement with
her
it's gonna always be about how can you
demonstrate that she's a person of value
and dignity in front of your children
and
not front of your children you have to
treat her that way always talk
positively about her
don't fight and yell and scream because
fighting yelling and screaming
only ends up in piles of bodies it's a
complete waste of time and energy most
of the time
unless there's a major abuse or you know
drug
use or breaking the law things like that
and so at the end of the day you have to
choose to honor this woman
and for some reason you chose to walk
away from her instead of honoring her
the first time so you're going to figure
out how to do all these things anyway
and when it comes to your kids you're
going to have to make sure
beyond a shadow of a doubt that you show
up you never miss
you never miss don't
bring a parade of other people through
their life until you are
confident that somebody is stable and
has their best interest in mind as well
make sure that you and your wife can
show up to parent conferences together
that y'all can show up to
mother and to i mean school plays
together things like that
you're gonna have to be in each other's
lives you're gonna have to be yeah
and you're gonna have to probably go see
somebody and work on
your childhood stuff you're the
separation from your parents you're
still rattling around in your head
that's still a point of hurt and failure
for you
you have to choose to not be angry
you're gonna have to choose to be a
person who
just lets things go right that's called
wisdom and maturity and growth
probably enough to get your butt in a
gym and learn how to be physically
able to take care of yourself to honor
your own body because you don't think
you do right now
you're gonna have to do all these things
and so here's what i'm telling you
right that's a tall list it's a tall
order you basically have to re
re-imagine how you live daryl and then
go make it happen
here's the cool thing i know that you
can you wouldn't be calling me if you
weren't interested in that i know that
you can
yeah and i know that your kids are worth
it and now you're committed to not
replaying the life that you were given
early on in your road
right yeah that one that told you
hey mom and dad broke up and it's
probably somewhat a little bit tiny bit
your fault
and they didn't uh stay connected
because
you mean you really got in the way there
right whatever that message is
dad wanted away from her so bad that he
ended up getting away from you too or
whatever the story that you still tell
yourself
at the end of the day it's not your
fault you're gonna have to work through
that stuff and man
if there's a chance work through it with
a partner work through it with somebody
who's been ride or die for 10 years
maybe not maybe i'm too optimistic man
but i can tell you i don't know a
marriage that hasn't had a crossroads
that says hey this is this is
probably not working out for us or why
do we even do this or what are we doing
or i cross this line or she crossed that
line or whatever whatever
they can't get in a room and say hey i
said
forever and if you still mean forever
we'll figure this out
because you're gonna have to figure it
out anyway or that
forest fire of trauma goes to the next
generation and the next generation
and the next generation and so on and so
forth
so daryl thanks so much for that call
brother thank you for being a brave guy
not a lot of guys would get on the air
and talk with me like you did so i'm
grateful for you
thanks for your willingness to clean up
the mess after y'all make it
and at least on my behalf thank you for
considering one last time
do i have to push this button is this
thing a foregone conclusion have i
screwed
up this bad is she that
unlikable unlovable that we can't get in
a room
probably with a therapist and figure
this thing out
i'll be rooting for you man rooting for
you rooting for you
and if this thing is final if y'all do
go to the courthouse together and sign
those papers
walk out in that parking lot and look
each other eye and say from this point
forward
we are friends we honor one another we
treat each other with dignity
and we love these kids more than they
will ever understand until they have
their own kids right
that's the narrative and that's the
story